[Musik]
dann kommt es nach den chaotischen
Wahlen weiterhin zu
bürgerkriegsähnlichen
zuständenundente der UN Generalsekretär
ein sofortiges Ende der Kampfhandlungen
hat der Präsident die sofortige
Entwaffnung der Aufständischen Milizen
GEF diese Entwicklung auch für
Österreich zuneh ist erstm zu
kampfandlungen in der hat die
Bundesregierung den Einsatz des
Bundesheeres zur militärischen
Landesverteidigung
beschlossen
mein Name bin der kompanieomandant der
Zen
assistenzkompanie grundsätzlich
versuchen wir hier die illegale
Migration und schleppkriminalität zu
verhindern aufgrund dessen dass wir als
bereits assistenzkompanie hier vort sind
ist es natürlich dann unsere Aufgabe
sollte sich das Gefahrenpotenzial
erhöhen den Ersteinsatz hier
dementsprechend wahrzunehmen
alle
der Schutz der Landesgrenzen ist
natürlich die ureigenste Eigenschaft des
Bundesheers verfassungsmäßig verankert
und
unumstößlich mein Name Istan Schachner
und ich bin
militärpizist für uns hat sich die
lagefolg dargestellt wir haben ein
Funkspruch erhalten von einem Wachposten
an der Grenze wir hatten bereits eine
Konfliktpartei mit ca 20 Personen
Tendenz steigend wo so ausgesehen hätte
als würde sie in nächster Zeit versuchen
in das österreichche Staatsgebiet
einzudringen z.B im benachbarten Land
bricht der Bürgerkrieg aus und es ist
relativ nah der Grenze dann wie das
bundesarmiert dann kommen wir und
versuchen einfach nur zu verhindern dass
sich dieser Bürgerkrieg auf unser
Bundesgebiet
ausweitet bin der Wachtmeister Hotwagner
Sil B gruppenkant beim banztier 35 wir s
infistisch vorgangen Schutz entlang in
die Ortschaft sichergestellt die
Bewohner haben gefragt was wir d machen
wir dann erklärt dass im benachbarten
Land ein Konflikt zwischen zwei Parteien
stattgefunden hat hab wir gesagt dass
sie KESt mssen dass wir da dass wir das
regeln wir zeigen einfach wir sind da
und wir schützen die Grenze wir haben
auch gesehen wir haben keine tung oben
auf dem Panzern und auch die
österreichplage auf den Antennen
montiert eben zu zeigen die Wiz Stellung
und wir halten dieses Gelände beste
Kampf ist immer der der nicht funden hat
man strebt nicht den Kampf und den Krieg
an sondern natürlich dass man das ganze
abwert bevor das ganze
passiert wir wurden von der
Militärpolizei alarmiert da sind wir
dann sofort zur Stelle gewesen sind da
zu mit der Polizei aufgestoßen und
wurden eingewiesen in der Lage versuchen
die Situation zu deeskalieren zeigt
Präsenz Fragen keine durchführen ja ich
bin oberwachtmeisterer AK nöz bei der
ersten aufklärungskompanie in misselbach
stellvertretender zugskommandant so
einer Verantwortung ist man sich
natürlich bewusst wie man jetzt wirklich
in einer Situation wie diese regieren
würde ist natürlich unmöglich zu sagen
allerdings bin ich mir sehr wohl bewusst
dass meine Entscheidungen über das Leben
anderer und formalen auch über das Leben
meiner Kameraden
entscheidet kommandantenverantwortung
ist unteilbar und wird das auch immer
sein mich hat eigentlich immer schon
fasziniert generell Panzergrenadiere ein
die Mischung ist zwischen Infanterie und
trotzdem dem starken Element den panz
dabei bin Wachtmeister Hofmann Sophie
und ich bin panzerkomant beim
panzerierpon
35 sobald der infanteristische Schutz
steht qui die einzelnen Leute eingesetzt
sind wird der Panzer nachgezogen alles
unter Sicherung Unterstützung von den
Kampfpanzern österreichische bundeseh
ist wie eine versicher
niemand zahlt gerne Versicherung ein
aber wenn esash kannst hoffen dass eine
gute
hast also die aufkleidungstruppe dient
hauptsächlich zur
Informationsbeschaffung wir verwenden
unsere Beobachtungsstation auf dem Husar
oben da haben wir eine taxikamera
genauso wie ein Wärmebildgerät und
können dann das angelände
Scannen für den einenm das seltsam
wirken wir widmen unseren Leben eine
Aufgabe die wir hoffen nie erfüllen zu
müssen aber wenn man jetzt in die Welt
schaut Ukraine wenn man mit diesen
Leuten spricht das ist eine Hölle die
niemand durchleben möchte und niemand
durchleben
sollte